diese katastrophe würde das ende der
raumfahrt bedeuten eine kettenreaktion
an deren ende die zerstörung der
allermeisten satelliten rund um die erde
steht dass kessler syndrom ausgelöst
durch weltraumschrott und dieses syndrom
das ist gar nicht so unwahrscheinlich
wenn wir nicht bald anfangen den
weltraumschrott weg zu räumen
jetzt hat ein europäischer satellit zum
ersten mal ein manöver zum aufsammeln
von weltraumschrott absolviert klicks um
science-fiction hier gibt es täglich
neue science videos abonniert den
channel gerne herzlich willkommen immer
wieder schlittern wir daran vorbei ist
gab bereits 200 kollisionen im orbit der
erde und jede produziert wieder neue
schrott teilchen inzwischen geht man von
166 millionen trümmerteilen aus die um
die erde schwirren 7600 tonnen extrem
gefährlicher müll
wir sind im moment quasi zeuge eines
kessler syndroms in zeitlupe
spektakulärer höhepunkt 2009 stoßen der
us-satellit nummer 33 das iridium
satellitentelefon netzes gewicht eine
halbe tonne und der russische satellit
cosmos 2251 zusammen bei einer
aufprallgeschwindigkeit von rund 40000
kilometern pro stunde bleibt von beiden
satelliten nichts mehr übrig außer rund
100.000 schrottteilen sie haben die
möglichkeit für den nächsten unfall
deutlich erhöht zum beispiel eine
kollision mit der ss der internationalen
raumstation wie am 24 märz 2015 ein
schrott teil dieser koalition steuert
mit hoher geschwindigkeit auf die iss zu
es stammt vom russischen satelliten
kosmos 2251 die nah sagt kann eine
schwere beschädigung der station nicht
ausschließen für die astronauten gibt es
nur eine rettung 2 an die iss angedockte
russische sojus kapseln im fall der
katastrophe könnten sie sofort abdocken
und zur erde zurückfliegen
die nasa rechnet also ganz konkret mit
einer schlimmen katastrophe bis hin zur
vernichtung der ss also sie kann sie
nicht ausschließen und bereitet sich
deshalb darauf vor laut esa chef johann
dietrich wörner ist weltraumschrott eine
globale herausforderung jetzt endlich
muss man sagen wird an einer lösung
gearbeitet die britische universität hat
erstmals einen satelliten ausgesetzt um
das aufsammeln von weltraumschrott zu
testen
der name des experiments
remove debris also auf deutsch entfernen
trümmer und das scheint gelungen zu sein
dafür im erd orbit ausgesetzter klein
satellit wurde mit hilfe eines netzes
eingefangen und zum absturz gebracht
dafür wurde das netz in fünf metern
entfernung ausgeworfen und der satellit
eingefangen zitat um diese
netztechnologie zum einfachen vom
weltraum welt zu entwickeln haben wir
sechs jahre lang mit parabelflügen und
in speziellen fallschirm und thermischen
vakuumkammern getestet so der
projektleiter bei airbus ingo ritter der
bus ist einer der projektbeteiligten und
bei dem verfahren mit dem netz wird es
nicht bleiben in den kommenden monaten
soll eine hauptschule zum einsamen
getestet werden und ein optisches
navigationssystem um die trümmer zu
orten doch ob die technik dann im großen
rahmen eingesetzt werden das ist noch
sehr fraglich bisher gibt es nämlich
keinerlei vereinbarung zum aufnehmen von
weltraumschrott niemand fühlt sich
verantwortlich und ein problem ist noch
vollkommen ungeklärt was machen wir mit
alten großen schrott satelliten die
steuerungs los durch das all fliegen der
8,2 tonnen schweren satelliten corot
envisat ist so ein kandidat seit april
2012 fliegt er vollkommen unkontrolliert
im erdorbit ihn einzufangen und zu
zerstören dürfte zig millionen kosten
geld das niemand ausgeben will wenn
dieses problem aber nicht gelöst wird
dann haben wir ein viel größeres problem
beim kessel syndrom wird dann nämlich so
ziemlich alles im airport zerstört
satelliten für gps telefonie internet
wettervorhersagen und so weiter und so
fort dazu noch die iss die
internationale raumstation und raumfahrt
ist dann gar nicht mehr möglich ein
gürtel von schrottteilen würde die erde
um schließen wir würden um jahrzehnte
zurückgeworfen werden es wäre eine
riesige katastrophe für die gesamte
menschheit was denkt ihr über den
weltraumschrott was muss getan werden
schreibt es in die kommentare
sobald wir weitere fortschritte erzielt
werden da gibt es ja natürlich ein neues
video wenn er das nicht verpassen und
wenn ihr immer garantiert über aktuelle
videos informiert werden wollt dann
endet mich bei whatsapp nur dann bekommt
ihr das aktuelle video deutlich vor
allen anderen formiert persönlicher
handy einfach hier draufklicken und da
drunter geht es weiter mit dafür auch
draufklicken live überwachung durch
satelliten tausende neue mini satelliten
im orbit bis dann
bleibt dran